[Music]
I don't think it is to prepare you for
this
like it's easier finale for us how
dramatic crazy emotional is it going to
be I mean you're gonna get all of the
emotions you're gonna get the love
you're gonna get the tears you're gonna
get the laughter and so the journey was
a roller coaster I felt everything in
that last week and there was intense and
I mean that's all gonna play out I
really can't say right now
any type of certainty oh it's gonna be
it's gut-wrenching
it's absolutely gut-wrenching what
happened in the Maldives is it's it's
beautiful in its brutal at the same time
and it's it's crazy to have the same in
all in one storm but you know what Ari
fell into Becca did - she's in love with
two men Blake and Garrett and she's
making an impossible choice and it
literally brings her to her knees how
are you and your fiance prepping for the
finale airing and for like the media
circus that's gonna hit you because
you've been through this once before
we're just ready we're just ready to be
done to be us in public and so I know
it's gonna be crazy when that moment
comes but it's gonna be so worth it and
so I'm just so excited for that day
[Music]